l'humiliation c'était la chose qui était
voulue en plus gratuite
[Musique]
au milieu de la nuit
oui
1h du matin enfin
les très vite les portiers les
portières s'ouvrent puisque ce sont des
wagons abestiaux des gens pyjamas avec
rayé qui se précipite et qui nous font
sortir très vite les aboiements de chien
cet éclairage très très dur
du fait qu'il y a sur le quai c'est
lampe
projetée vers la lumière projetée vers
les wagons et puis
une sortie très très rapide et wagons
avec
ses
bagnards pour nous ils sont habillés
comme des Bagnas et qui nous font sortir
de train les chiens qui aboient
et nous font mettre très enfin tout ça
se passe très très vite je crois que
c'est une question de dignité je crois
que c'est parce que
ce qu'était le camp
qui était cette volonté d'humiliation
moi je dis toujours cette volonté tout
le monde mais c'est le sentiment qu'on a
c'est qu'on a eu faim on a eu soif on a
eu froid horriblement froid on a eu on
avait sommeil moi le sommeil ça
m'apparaît être une chose terrible parce
que les derniers jours avant la
libération de Bergen melzen je travaille
à la cuisine on rentrait même pas en
dormait pas de la nuit enfin c'était
terriblement du sommeil moi je je
dormais en marchant et mais
l'humiliation c'était la chose qui était
voulue en plus gratuite donc par exemple
au moment où on allait se mettre à
manger on pensait
donner un coup de pied dans le bol dans
lequel on était censé manger alors où on
mangeait pas on ramassait ce qui était
par terre enfin
et tout le temps c'était une humiliation
permanente on est donc évacué avec la
vie son pensée train qui était des quel
est le train complètement ouvert des
plateaux à bois
d'autres
un peu plus haut pour le charbon mais là
c'est des plateaux à bois on était
entassés et tellement entassés que comme
on se battait pour se faire un peu de
place on peut même pas ce soir
il y en avait qui essayait de vous jeter
par dessus la rambarde et
pour se faire de la place simplement
pour rester ma sœur avait des traces de
griffes
qu'elle avait eu certaines déportés
qu'il avait griffé dans le
dans le wagon pour essayer de la sortir
dehors et il y avait que des femmes ou
c'était mélangé
on n'était pas mélangé
femme et
puis on a fait ce cadre d'abord on est
passé alors ce qui est extraordinaire on
est passé de la vie c'est le
sud-est alors après on est passé très
rapidement
après j'ai pas le Tchécoslovaquie les
faubourg de Prague et dans les faubourgs
de Prague comme on était dans ses wagons
tout à fait ouvert on passait pas très
loin des maisons et les
checks avaient dû avoir déjà plusieurs
trains qui étaient passés ils nous ont
envoyé du pain ils ont envoyé ce qu'il
pouvait alors on recevait ce qui ce qui
patoum enfin tout de même pas mal puis
quand on s'est arrêté dans une gare il
venait apporter des sauts de dos enfin
et du jour même mon passé la frontière
c'est fini
quand je pense à dire quand je pense à
tout ça
il y a une chose que
qui est vraiment
effroyable c'est la mort des enfants
c'est insupportable
insupportable
de penser à ses enfants pensez aux
enfants qui ont été séparés de leur mère
qui sont arrivés comme ça tout petit ou
dans les bras d'une éducatrice
c'est insupportable insupportable
[Musique]